[Music]
on this monday night the evolving advice
about masks rethinking how much
protection we really need
with the more transmissible variants and
such high case load
we need to really think about improving
our mass what you can do as more cases
of
highly contagious variants are confirmed
in canada
getting it in writing we're being told
we'll just trust us
ottawa under pressure to ensure vaccine
delivery promises
aren't broken plus a military takeover
in myanmar
this is bad news its leader detained and
the future of democracy
in peril and returning the favor the
show of support for captain sir tom
moore
who's been diagnosed with covet 19.
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
more cases of the new highly contagious
variants of covid19
have been confirmed in canada 69 people
in ontario
are now known to have the variant first
detected in britain
and the first case of the south african
variant has also been confirmed there
in alberta there are now 51 known cases
of the more
contagious variants and bc has confirmed
18 known cases of variants of concern
including
four of the south african variant how
widespread they are
exactly in canada at this point is not
certain more genomic testing
is being ramped up what is certain is
that they spread much faster from person
to person and many experts say we need
to do more to stop that spread including
rethinking the masks we wear heather
urix west has our top story tonight
it's become the mandated way of life
under covet 19.
we wear masks every time we buy
groceries at work
or at school indoors and even some
outdoor spaces
canada's masking policies have developed
over time
based on what we've learned about the
virus but as the virus changes
some experts say masking policies need
to change again
with the more transmissible variants and
such high case load
we need to really think about improving
our masks one way you can do that
is by double masking wearing two masks
can help improve both filtration
and fit if you do it right two cloth
masks for example would impair airflow
and could force air to escape on the
sides
the best type of double masking is
probably to wear a surgical type mask
underneath
that provides really good filtration but
maybe it doesn't fit well because it has
gaps on the sides
you want it to sit flat on both sides
and fit your chin well as well
and then what you do is you basically
just put on your cloth mask the exact
same way
how much additional protection the extra
mask provides is really not yet known
but as the new variants circulate other
countries are re-evaluating policies
and advice in france homemade cloth
masks that do not meet minimum standards
are no longer enough to meet the
country's mask mandate
and in the u.s dr anthony fauci is
recommending
better masks as well if you have a
physical covering with one layer
you put another layer on it just makes
common sense
that it likely would be more effective
adding the double mask
might incrementally help a little bit in
the grand
scheme though i think you know it's much
better to aim for people to have
appropriate masks and use them
effectively
the public health agency of canada
currently recommends canadians wear
high quality masks non-medical cloth
masks should be three layers including a
filter
and cover a person's mouth and nose
a best practice still not practiced by
all
heather urex west global news calgary
in ontario nearly 300 000 students went
back to in-person learning today and
new masking and testing measures are
coming into force mats are now mandatory
for students in grades one to three in
ontario that includes outdoors
when they can't properly distance and
voluntary asymptomatic testing will soon
be expanded to schools across ontario
the government says both rapid and pcr
tests will be used
and up to 50 000 tests could be
processed per week
it will be up to local public health
units to decide where to deploy those
tests
public health experts warn variants are
so much more transmissible and explosive
growth in cases is likely in the weeks
ahead
before vaccines are widely available and
in ontario there are already worrying
signs toronto public health says
an outbreak at a toronto meat plant is
linked to the uk variant
78 people at that plant have tested
positive for covid19
two of them for the uk variant
to mutate viruses have to replicate
to replicate viruses need
human cells so our
job is not to give it to them distance
distance distance in
any form you can create it
to try to better detect the variance
mandatory testing is now in place at
canada's largest
airport all international passengers
arriving at toronto's pearson airport
must now be screened for covet 19.
mandatory testing could be in place for
all international passengers arriving in
canada as soon as thursday
passengers will also have to pay to
quarantine in hotels while they wait
for their test results key to getting
ahead of the new variants is getting
vaccines into the arms of canadians on
that front canada is still moving
slowly just over 964 000 doses have been
administered across the country
that means about 2.2 percent of the
canadian population has received at
least
one dose shipments of vaccines have
slowed down because of cutbacks in
production at pfizer and moderna plants
in europe
and as abigail beeman explains the
threat of export controls in europe
is still looming you only have
a a verbal assurance is what you're
saying today
i have multiple assurances through
myself and through
minister haiju and from the prime
minister that
vaccine shipments to canada will not be
affected by this mechanism
the international trade minister grilled
for not getting a promise in writing
that canada's vaccine shipments won't be
affected by the european union's new
export controls
we're being told we'll just trust us and
and and take our good word
that that the rug isn't going to be
pulled out from beneath you later
we are on track to do that for all
canadians who wish it for free
by september we have vaccines on route
to canada and being deployed
across this country on monday and
tuesday of this week but this week just
79
000 doses from pfizer are coming and
four moderna
180 thousand 22 percent less than
originally expected
we are now virtually at a standstill
with no vaccines delivered to
saskatchewan in over a week
where is canada's mass vaccination
campaign
it's so scatter shock right now what's
happening in europe adds a new concern
while marying insists she has verbal
assurances canada's supply won't be
impacted by export controls
our country is not on the eu's list of
exempted countries
and while the eu discourages individual
countries from making unilateral
decisions
belgium has notified the eu of an
emergency measure though it's not
entirely clear what the plan is
canada's pfizer biontech vaccines are
coming from belgium i did speak to my
belgian counterpart
yesterday i did get assurances from
from the vice prime minister on canada's
shipments and and that that the
mechanism will not affect
canada's vaccine shipments ing says she
has a call scheduled with her
counterpart in spain that's where
canada's moderna vaccines are coming
from
abigail beeman global news ottawa in the
u.s
january was by far the deadliest month
of the pandemic
now there are some signs of hope with
vaccinations picking up new infections
have fallen for the third straight week
and hospitalizations are down too
as jackson proskow reports the question
now is whether america can stay ahead of
the highly contagious variants
these are tenuous days in the fight
against the pandemic
mixed with promise and the potential for
much more pain
people are actually becoming a little
less vigilant both because they
recognize the vaccines are
you know here and that they're rolling
out but then also because people are
just tired
95 000 americans died in the month of
january alone
and yet states are loosening
restrictions just as more contagious
virus variants from the uk south africa
and brazil creep
in there are now hundreds of cases in
more than half of the states
doctors are deeply worried you know it's
a race
to get the vaccines out and slow down
the spread
before this virus figures out a way to
outsmart
the treatments in the vaccines that
we've developed
mass vaccination sites continue to dole
out doses to the tune of more than one
million per day
25 million americans that's 10 percent
of the adult population
has now received at least one dose
doctors are being told they should no
longer hold second doses in reserve
because they now have the predictability
that the second dose will be there when
the time comes
but there's a catch the vaccines may be
less effective against those new virus
variants
if they take hold epidemiologists
believe a higher percentage of the
population will need the shot
to bring about hurt immunity if we were
aiming for somewhere around
70 percent or 75 percent in the fast
in the past now we're aiming for 80 85
percent
maybe 90 percent of the population to be
vaccinated until that happens the virus
remains a threat
the u.s is requiring masks on all forms
of mass transportation
planes trains and buses while officials
brace for a potential surge of new cases
in the next two months
fueled by those new variants
in jackson the biden administration
today announced it is ordering tens of
millions of dollars worth of rapid test
kits that can be used at home
tell us about that
donna this could be key to helping
people isolate when they have symptoms
it's a do-it-yourself
over-the-counter nasal swab kit that
goes into a reader
and delivers results by your smartphone
in about 15 minutes with 95
accuracy the biden administration says
it's spending about 230
million dollars to acquire these tests
from an australian company
they want to build domestic
manufacturing supply here in the us
and hope to deliver about 19 million
tests per month by the end of this year
all right jackson prosco in washington
thanks england is beginning what's being
called surge testing in regions where
the south african variant has been found
in the last six days 105 people across
england are confirmed to have the south
african variant 11 of them
had no links to travel that community
spread is what triggered the surge
testing
kovid 19 test kits are being sent out to
households in the high risk areas
and health care workers are going door
to door to swab about
80 000 people
south africa has received its first
batch of covid 19 vaccine
one million doses of the astrazeneca
vaccine were sent to johannesburg from
india
the shipment met by the prime minister
frontline healthcare workers are first
in line to get the shot
another half million doses are expected
later this month
clinical trials have shown vaccines made
by novovacks and johnson and johnson
appear to be less affected against
the south african variant in the
netherlands the health minister has
revealed half of all new cases there are
the uk variant
mass testing undertaken in january shows
the uk variant
was almost 50 percent more contagious
than the original version of the virus
the government there warns new strains
could start to trigger another surge
in the weeks ahead coup d'etat coming up
global condemnation for the military
power grab
in myanmar plus the wicked winter storm
moving up the east coast
the hard-fought battle for democracy in
myanmar has taken an ominous turn
in the early hours on monday the
military announced it has seized power
troops are patrolling the streets
democratically elected politicians have
been arrested
eric sorenson explains why the coup
happened now and what it means for
myanmar's future
an elected politician is taken away the
internet
cut off the military suddenly everywhere
on the streets of the capitol
and then confirmation on state tv
a state of emergency is set for one year
he says governance is handed over to the
commander-in-chief
on the left was sworn in the
democratically elected leader aung san
tsuchi
is in custody and has not been seen the
international community has called for
her immediate release
it's just outrageous it's deeply
disturbing there's a lot that we
that we don't know but what we do know
is that
democracy has been overturned by by
the generals for 60 years the military
has pulled the strings of power in
myanmar
also known as burma aung san tsuchi
campaigned for democratic reform and
spent almost 15 years under house arrest
when su chi led her nld party to a
second landslide victory last
fall over the military-backed party
military leaders declared fraud
i think the military realized that this
conflict was
was was real and she wasn't going to go
away it's another defining moment for
aung san tsuchi
she won the nobel peace prize as a
reformer but when the military attacked
rohingya muslims in 2017 amid charges of
ethnic cleansing
suchi's inaction and her defense of the
military before the international court
splintered her reputation worldwide in
canada
tsuchi had been recognized with rare
honorary citizenship
then became the first to have that honor
revoked
but sushi has always been popular in her
country
bob ray was the prime minister's envoy
to myanmar you're going to get a strong
reaction
she's in power because of a democratic
movement
uh as imperfect as it as it is
uh and that democratic movement is not
going to suddenly
you know disappear the streets are
mostly quiet in myanmar
people long accustomed to the military
running things with brutality
our country says this student leader is
just a bird learning to fly
now the army has broken our wings and
a fledgling democracy overnight has been
silenced
erik sorensen global news toronto
ahead millions hit by a nor'easter the
mess it's causing
a powerful nor'easter is working its way
across the u.s east coast tonight the
first major snowfall of the year
nearly a meter of heavy snow is expected
in new york by tuesday and that would
make it one of the biggest winter storms
in that city's history
the slow-moving system is packing gusty
winds and creating near blizzard
conditions there are widespread school
closures and
thousands of flights have been canceled
disrupting travel for millions
new york's governor is warning people
could be stranded
yes we've been through it before
but this this is a dangerous
life-threatening situation
a snow emergency has been declared in
several cities including washington new
york and boston as well as the entire
state of new jersey
the same fierce storm front is forecast
to hit parts of atlantic canada
early on tuesday another police incident
has sparked an outcry in the u.s
a nine-year-old girl was handcuffed and
pepper sprayed by officers in rochester
new york who were responding
to a report of family trouble a warning
the video is difficult to watch
this is your last chance otherwise
body cam footage shows officers trying
to force the girl into the back of a
police car
police warned several times they would
use pepper stray and the girl resisted
putting her feet into the car
then one officer reaches in and sprays
her
i got her i got it
a girl was taken to the hospital and
later released
the interim police chief has said it is
not okay for a nine-year-old to be
pepper sprayed and an investigation is
underway
less than a year ago daniel prud a
41-year-old black man
died while rochester police restrained
him with a spit hood
actor dustin diamond who starred in the
sitcom saved by the bell
has died wow a building with two
buildings one of whom is balding
diamond was widely known for his role as
the character screech in the high school
sitcom
and its spin-offs he was diagnosed with
stage four lung cancer
three weeks ago diamond was just 44
years old
caring for captain tom next britain's
beacon of hope
in the pandemic now in hospital himself
[Music]
he always likes to say he's in the
business of making people feel good
and so he never wanted the audience to
know if he had a problem
tony bennett's family has revealed a
secret they've kept for four years the
94 year old one of the world's greatest
singers has alzheimer's disease
he was diagnosed in 2016. his wife says
his best therapy is to sing
and make people smile bennett still
recognizes family members but they say
he has increasingly rare moments of
clarity and awareness
he is still singing and recorded an
album with lady gaga
after his diagnosis best wishes are
pouring in for captain sir tom moore the
100 year old veteran who walked laps in
his garden to raise money for britain's
national health service
moore has been diagnosed with covid19
he's in the hospital though not in
intensive care
but his age makes him very vulnerable
and as redmond shannon reports he's
being cared for by the health care
workers he did so much
to support 100 laps of his yard before
his 100th birthday a simple idea that
turned a small
coveted 19 fundraiser into almost 60
million dollars for healthcare workers
it also turned captain tom moore
into captain sir tom moore this is such
a
high award that says he get and from her
majesty as well
what more can anyone wish for than that
but the man who did so much to help is
now
in need of help captain tom's daughter
says the second world war veteran tested
positive for the virus
last week and was admitted to hospital
sunday
he needs assistance with his breathing
but is not in intensive care
given his age britons are worried his
smiling face was on the front of almost
every national newspaper on monday
captain tom moore has been
an inspiration to everybody in this
country
during this pandemic and i think our
thoughts and our prayers are
now with him and and with his family
it's not known how moore contracted
covet 19
he hadn't yet received the vaccine due
to medication he had been taking for a
recent bout of pneumonia
moore and his family had been on
vacation in barbados in december
a journey that was against government
advice but within travel rules
at the time his neighbours showing
nothing but support for their local hero
it's beautiful having him just on our
doorstep but um yeah
sending our positive thoughts out for
the family and him
make sure he's okay he's quite a mature
man being a hundred so
you just have to hope that he would be
okay you know
what he's done a lot of good for the nhs
raising all that money
captain tom's impact has been more than
just money and morale
he has inspired others to push their own
limits for some tremendous fundraising
feats
his family has praised the remarkable
efforts of those looking after captain
tom
the healthcare workers who took
inspiration from moore's efforts
are now giving back in the best way
possible redmond shannon global news
london the royal canadian mint has
unveiled a commemorative coin marking
black history month justice
fills your heart with pain
a virtual ceremony was held to reveal
the silver 20
coin it honors a part of black history
in nova scotia the coin features the
coat of arms of the black loyalists who
fought in the american revolution
many of them were freed slaves and they
settled in nova scotia
after the war between 1783 and 1785.
they were the largest group of people of
african descent to immigrate to nova
scotia
at any one time and that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen tonight's europe canada
waves crashing ashore in lower island
cove newfoundland and labrador we'd love
to see your corner of the country please
send your photo to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]